mr. Peter Peter England permanent
secretary in the Swedish Academy
this year's laureate please tell us
patek Mariano he's a French author he
was born in France 1945 he has written
some 30 different books mainly novels
but also written children's books she's
written movie scripts and so on but it
but he is a man known for this his
novels which are very very specific
small books 130 150 pages which are
always variations of the same theme
about memory about loss about identity
about seeking those are his important
things memory memory identity memory
identity and time which is his place in
the French literature
come again his place in French
literature
he saw his a well-known name in France
but no I think pretty well not not
anywhere else
is it translated into other languages oh
yes he's been translated into swedish I
think he's more translated into swedish
than in say english but but his is well
known and well read in from his books
are quite short his novels you say which
one would you recommend as a start if
you have if you read one doesn't know
his authorship one that I can recommend
this is about
it's called missing person it's a bit
we have neighbors were quite talkative
talking in my ear
missing persons he's very fond of the
detective genre any place with it and
it's a a story about a detective that
has lost his memory
and his final case is finding out who he
really is and his tracing he's following
his own steps tracing his own steps
through history to find out who he is
and it's a very fun it's a fun book he's
playing with the wrong but it's still
saying something very fundamental about
about memory and time history you say
can you spirits feel a special affinity
with this author you were being a
historian yourself what not not as a
historian but but as a person concerned
with memory which I think we all are and
he has a very special odd memory as we
write in in the motivation how it works
he is sort of possessed about his
attempts to try and reach back in time
doing it again again on a different
different ways and you can identify
yourself of course with this with these
attempts and he's very original ways to
do it returning he says I have walked
some of these streets so many times the
time has become transparent and it
believes in is that there are corridors
of time in specific places there are
corridors in times that you can that
opens up and that you can walk through
them and you can meet yourself have you
talked to him today
now we haven't established contact yet
but I hope to do it sir where does he
live right now I in in France in Paris
that is Imperator's also one of his main
millions for his for his writing he is
writing a lot about Paris he knows Paris
intimately he knows every backstreet
Paris is often in the books it's it's
part of the
it's an important part of the setting
sounds like if his accessible to the
ordinary reader it could become quite
popular oh yes I think he is his is not
difficult here right for one he writes
rather short books one of the 31 or 50
pages and he also it has a very simple
language but at the same time that the
language and words are used on are not
complicated as such but at the same time
the composition of the normal nose was
quite refined is very elegant books but
no I don't think his is difficult to
read in that way you can read him easily
one of his books in the afternoon have a
dinner and read another one in the
evening thank you Peter England from the
switch Academy